credo che dovremmo chiedergli il
permesso
lo chiamo
[Musica]
ed è avanti ore ma piace indebitamento
del canale di qualcosa ci sarebbe la tua
benedizione ragazzi non vi serve la mia
benedizione
ma seguiamo appropriazione indebita a
posto specie quando mi riprendete con
un'ottica proprio qui c'è già manca
quindi detta le battute dalle
inquadrature
federico mi fa una finta chiamata tali
per cui ragazzi è l'unica cosa che posso
dirvi è che prendere qualche portatelo
da voi
benvenuti siamo qui per un
appropriazione indebita su cucina
buttata in una giornata di 40 gradi
centigradi percepiti all'ombra di
vederli coop ci sfideremo in cucina
vinceranno certo migliore avete qualche
idea io ho un'idea può che lui non vive
a cavallo di battaglia
certo è come senti da mettiamo sa
cucinare
vi dico solo che avete pochissimo tempo
pochissimi minuti per prendere tutti gli
ingredienti
[Musica]
no
basta i ragazzi allora ragazzi io farò
un piatto che mi riesce molto bene
solitamente ovvero farò l'amatriciana ma
avrò l'impedimento di avere il gesso
abbraccio ma il vantaggio di saper
cucinare
enrico non sa fare allora la mia
amatriciana è composta da polpa di
pomodoro guanciale mi dispiace
tricologia preso tagliato e corino già
grattugia vergogna pasta e perché io
questo sono non ti offendere ma per il
mio impedimento o posso dire beh
ingredienti già pronti questo andrà a
discapito del tuo piatto vi mostrerò mia
ingredienti chiaramente io non dirò la
ricetta perché voglio ottenere light
fino alla fine è un piatto segretissimo
degli spaghetti un po di aglio del
peperoncino e dell'odio vuole basta
farla vasta io dei peperoncini e andiamo
avanti
ho già messo l'acqua sul fuoco che
faccio da tempo che porto ho visto che
starebbe faresti in realtà noi già
votato solo convinto dei risultati
lui è la prima volta che sto facendo
questo piatto paiolo a me sono parole
bene il mio cavallo di battaglia ragazzi
guanciale dove siamo sul fuoco bisogna
stare molto attenti alla cottura del
guanciale perché rischi vi carbonizzano
da un momento all'altro io al contrario
di gianmarco mi dedicherò al taglio
degli ingredienti giusto per fare quindi
andrò a prendere l'attrezzo migliore per
il mestiere allora allora allora loro
ecco qua perfetta questa che il coltello
preso il coltello e l'apprezzo migliore
dello chef o svestito l'angelo della sua
camicia e adesso lo priverò della sua
anima perché sono un senso a cuore le
acque nostre stanno già bollino c'è chi
sa già
ma cosa sto ancora devo far sì che lo
prendo uno scottex su cui c'è un troppo
giare il guanciale un topo l'avrei fatto
più spesso invece è sottilissimo bisogno
di sapere quanto è piccante questo
peperoncino ed addio è calato intero non
è buonissimo la fase rischiata beh non è
potentissimo figlio in un taglio
raffinato qua vedo veramente il
guanciale che di un po non è sbagliato e
giusto sentire il paese ci sta e che
troppo fino non è un tappo fino di un mi
piace il taglio che non è colpa mia
ora accetta di una cosa ancora non posso
mettere robben padella che ci state
parla mi dispiace con la polpa e torno
da lei ma lasciamo andare per 10 15
minuti che mariposa un attimo lascia un
po the robber le olio in padella aglio
peperoncino chiama bassa e partiamo con
la rosolatura vi consiglio anche di
inclinare la padella per avere una
rosolatura omogenea che non mif a
controllarsi rom stock amano concesso
col copri siccome il sale principalmente
viene da guanciale e pecorino acqua
della pasta e sugo vanno salati molto
poco ma che cazzo c'è del mio no potrei
mettere guanciale nava sarà definito il
piatto vero olio e pasta il piatto
segreto di enrico non ti lascio parlare
così del mio cavallo di guantanamo
saliamo l'acqua sto cazzo ne so se vuoi
mica andiamo in cottura la pasta come
potete vedere non niente da questo
pentolino quindi la
toglierò la passa molto prima della sua
cottura e finirò di cuocerla nella
padella con un po di acqua di cottura
così da creare una pasta semplice come
aglio olio e peperoncino anche una
cremina che vi farà non so se si può
dire questo termine come il suo ci mette
un po di sale e ci butto il guanciale e
poi anche un pochino di pepe al
guanciale
guardate come stanno lavorando questo
con la mano affacciato sul muro e per
quell'altro non si sa come core senza
una manovra po come dire il maestro
scolapasta le alziamo la fiamma
leggermente è mantechiamo ragazzi ce
l'hai e la la la la
acqua di cottura
ci siamo ragazzi abbiamo finito parto
con il piazzamento butta la pasta mia
sarò il primo ad assaggiare per vedere
che cosa vi rifilerà sembra buono
potrete accomodarvi vediamo il mio
sfidante come se l'è cavata
la donna ha cantato con e sorprendente
ecco il cameraman di oggi prende un bel
boccone comunque
sento un buon contrasto di sapori una
cremina devo dire di classe la cottura è
ottima come piace a me
enrico dopo di rho il mio voto perché
dove assaggiare prima al suo piace la
pasta è praticamente cotta andiamo a
ultimare le procedure ma guardate che è
fatto tutto su del muro ma che chiedere
a dover giro hanno usato sugo è appunto
è quindi è mio momento e anche frutta ma
ragazzi non ci vuole niente a prendere
questa pasta bella non ci vuole niente a
renderla bella o più amatriciana
ecco il mio piattamente cucina romana
the fatto il fighetto piatto a mostrare
allora come l'odore io sento solo quella
tua potrebbe essere una cosa positiva o
una cosa negativa che c'è un errore
troppo sale o dura della pasta la
ritengo eccellente signora ma niente e
lennon chino fresco che non c'è che dire
l'olio avrebbe solo neo bomber e il
piatto andò da dire piatto tipico della
tradizione cottura della pasta giusta ma
basta molto cremosa molto ben fatta
spinge parecchio messo che poi a master
sempre non si sa dove tirano le
forchette sofia e lo devo dire rispetto
alla cucina di guglielmo qua siamo già
piatti stellata il guanciale secondo me
che gli dà st botta sapida esagerata non
è tra le migliori amatriciane che ho
fatto sono merda sei e mezzo
e ben fatta anche qui sento però lo
stesso errore chiediamo un culo a
guglielmo è vero parlano segnano
accusare stavo pensando alla scena da
fare auto scordato il sapore del tempo
mi devo dire buona cottura anche questa
ben fatta ha detto tu tagliare la torta
viene tecnica volpi non l'ha detto
inquadrare nonna di non dire egli venga
tagliato ovviamente alla finestra che
venga tagliato il chip ad alessandro
davanti alla finestra ma cosa ti combina
ore si fa gli ariani resta voi che non
venga vinta ma piatto dire le do un bel
sette e mezzo ma gianmarco do un 8
entrambe le parti erano fatte bene solo
che non si può confrontare quello che è
un'amatriciana con un aglio al
peperoncino a mio parere o fai un angolo
che verón chino da sturbo ma la
matriciana per me è che buona io forse
invece dalla vittoria te perché la mia
basic è che la mia mente chan è buona ma
ne ho fatte altri che erano molto molto
più buona di queste quindi a livello di
qualità della ricetta secondo me l'hai
fatta meglio che questa è la mia aglio
olio e peperoncino migliore che abbia
mai fatto in vita mia
ragazzi